- MM, BROTHERS, BROTHERS,
BROTHERS,
SEE, WHEN ARE WE GON' THINK
OF OURSELVES AS MORE THAN THIS?
[chuckles]
WHAT Y'ALL DOING,
Y'ALL ROLLIN'? HUH?
[chuckles]
FLIPPIN'? STOOPIN'?
BOXIN'? MAXIN'?
CHAXIN'?
I USED TO STOOP.
OH, YEAH.
I USED TO FLIP, ROLL, YOU KNOW,
WHATEVER YOU WANT TO CALL IT.
[chuckles]
ME AND MY CREW,
WE WOULD GET INTO ACTIVITY,
MUCH LIKE YOURSELVES.
YOU SEE, THE PROBLEM WAS,
WE WERE ONLY PERPETUATING
THE STEREOTYPE THE SYSTEM
ALREADY ASSUMES ABOUT US.
MM.
YOU SEE, WE NEED TO
STOP FEEDING INTO
THE PRECONCEIVED NOTIONS
THAT WE ARE ALL--
- GREAT JOB, YOU GUYS.
YOU REALLY WORK HARD TODAY.
I WISH I COULD PAY YOU MORE,
BUT YOU KNOW HOW IT IS.
EH--WHO ARE YOU, HUH?
WHAT DO YOU WANT?
- I-I DON'T KNOW.
AS YOU WERE.
- AS YOU WERE WHAT,
SMART GUY?
[cursing in foreign language]
- MM. OH, HO.
BROTHERS, BROTHERS, BROTHERS,
LOOK AT YOURSELVES.
PANTS HANGIN' OFF YOUR ASS,
LOOKING LIKE
A COUPLE OF CLOWNS--
WHICH YOU ARE. OKAY,
ENJOY THE BIRTHDAY CELEBRATION.
- GIMME YOUR [bleep] MONEY,
BITCH!
- NO! NO!
- I SAID,
GIMME YOUR [bleep] MONEY, BITCH!
- OH! OH!
- [grunts]
- BROTHER, BROTHER, BROTHER.
- SIR, EVERYBODY
IN THIS SELF-DEFENSE CLASS
HAS ALREADY PAID
TO PARTICIPATE.
IF YOU'RE INTERESTED,
YOU CAN SIGN UP ONLINE.
- I'M INTERESTED.
- GOOD.
- THAT'S WHY I CAME OVER HERE.
I'M INTERESTED.
I'M GON' THINK ABOUT IT.
- THANK YOU, SIR.
NOW, LADIES, IT'S GON' GET
REALLY INTENSE TODAY,
NO MATTER WHAT HAPPENS.
I WILL BE GROPING
YOUR BREASTASIES
AS IF YOU WERE BEING ATTACKED
LIKE A REAL ATTACKER.
- BROTHER, BROTHER, MY BROTHER.
NOW, I WAS WATCHING YOU.
NOW, YOU OLDER BROTHERS
NEED TO BREAK THE STEREOTYPE
AND STOP BEING SO PREACHY.
- YOU KNOW WHAT?
- MM?
- I'M PREACHY?
- MM.
- COME ON.
[scoffs]
YOU PREACHY, MAN.
PLUS, YOU OLDER THAN ME.
- I'M NINE YEARS OLD.
I GOT BENJAMIN BUTTON'S DISEASE.
- S--I'M DONE. I'M DONE.